[Music]
Before starting this video, we just
wanna thank you for supporting our channel.
It truly means a lot to know what a wonderful
community we've built together.
Without further ado, let's get to today's
topic on the Effects of Growing Up with a
Single Parent.
Although having two parents in the picture
is definitely beneficial for kids growing
up, it's not always the case.
There are many children today who are going
through life with just a single parent, and
when they reach adulthood, many of them become
highly successful, happy individuals.
Both negative and positive psychological effects
of having a single parent have been studied
extensively.
Interestingly, many new studies suggest that
divorce in particular might not necessarily
be the root cause of psychological issues,
despite previous schools of thought.
Instead, these issues might simply be the
result of traumatic memories in general.
Let's check out 7 Effects of Growing up with
a Single Parent.
Boys tend to be more idle in young adulthood.
Sometimes, specific genders seem to react
in different ways to growing up with a single
parent.
In terms of boys, some studies have suggested
that they're more likely to be idle in young
adulthood.
This includes things like being unproductive
and even dropping out of school.
While boys are more likely to experience this,
it can definitely happen with girls as well.
Girls are at a higher risk for teen pregnancy.
Multiple surveys and studies have shown a
link between single-parent homes and teen
pregnancy.
While unplanned pregnancies aren't always
a bad thing, teen pregnancies in particular
can involve certain issues and complications
such as lack of financial opportunities and
access to higher education.
Some have theorized that this correlation
is due to the lack of a male figure in the
household, which can have negative psychological
effects on a young girl.
Single-parent families can actually be more
beneficial in some cases.
With more and more children growing up in
single-parent households, more research is
being done on not only the negative effects
but also the positive ones.
Some studies have pointed out that in some
cases, a single family household can actually
be more beneficial.
The main example would be an extremely stressful
two-parent home versus a peaceful relaxed
single-parent home.
When there is extreme conflict, violence or
stress in a two-parent home, a single-parent
home is actually a much more beneficial environment
for the child.
That's definitely something worth keeping
in mind as we list some of the negative effects
here.
Kids with a single parent might end up having
a stronger relationship with that parent.
There's always a very special bond that forms
between children and their parents, but one
study suggests that in a single-parent home,
that relationship could potentially be even
stronger and unique in a way that is unseen
in two-parent homes.
Not only is the relationship often stronger
in this situation but the children and parents
are more dependent on each other, more affectionate
and more likely to work together towards a
common goal.
Before we continue to the next point, we want
to share with you a recommended video from
Better Help.
Haesue talks about Seven Ways To Overcome
Emotional Neglect.
If you find yourself to be somebody who suffered
from emotional neglect, you may want to check
it out after this video.
Kids with single parents might end up being
less satisfied in life.
In a slightly alarming study, research was
done on tens of thousands of individuals to
test their overall feeling of satisfaction
in life.
The study found a small but persistent decrease
in life satisfaction among those who had grown
up with a single mother throughout childhood.
They found that these individuals were less
likely to experience educational and economic
success and good physical health.
Additionally, they found a connection between
single mother childhoods and unmet relationship
goals.
But remember, there was only a small decrease
in life satisfaction when compared to those
with two parents.
There could be an increased risk of psychiatric
issues; there's a huge wealth of scientific
literature which states single-parent homes
are a risk factor for a number of mental health
issues in children including depression and
psychological distress.
Once again, we're not saying this happens
to all children in these situations, but there's
definitely a link.
Also, we have to mention that the trauma of
potentially negative memories might be the
root cause, not necessarily single-parent
homes specifically.
Children with single parents benefit immensely
from a strong relationship with their grandparents.
Let's end things with something positive;
what can be done to avoid some of these negative
effects and help children in these situations?
One study suggested a perfect solution; encourage
a strong relationship with the child's grandparents.
The recent study discovered that this simple
act can considerably boost social skills and
help reduce behavioral problems in adolescents.
This is a great example of how psychological
research can really help those in need.
What do you think about kids growing up in
single-parent homes?
Do any of our viewers have first-hand experience
with these situations?
Let us know in the comments below. And as always,
thank you for your continued support.